it happened again someone threw some
good old-fashioned military Secrets up
on the War Thunder forums and for those
keeping count this is the 12th time it's
happened that's 2 that's Touch This this
time the topic in question was the F-117
Nighthawk America's first operational
stealth aircraft the documents posted
which included a flight manual aren't
top secret exactly but still can't just
be posted randomly online due to other
forms of classification the aircraft is
old actually so this info isn't really
that new it entered service in 83 and
then served for five years while fully
classified before eventually being a
major part of the Gulf War now that
still doesn't mean you should be you
know leaking military info just to get
bust for your favorite in-game play stop
it
get some help but
stop the nearly dozen people before this
person from doing exactly the same thing
so I have this sneaking suspicion that
we'll be chatting about this one again
soon